sensibiliser tous les publics aux
valeurs de l'abbé Pierre reconnu comme
défenseur des plus démunis l'abbé Pierre
était sans cesse à la recherche de
justice et de paix c'est pourquoi la
ville de coinière a décidé de lui rendre
hommage on est en recherche d'un sujet
qui amène à parler de valeurs qui
aujourd'hui sont en difficulté
d'ailleurs notamment les valeurs de
solidarité les valeurs d'ouverture vers
l'autre et on a trouvé que la baé pierre
était une belle figure et la plupart
d'entre nous l'avaient connu et donc
cette belle figure on s'est dit elle
incarne ses valeurs et pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas faire à coignère une année
à baépierre dans cette lignée l'espace
Alphonse d'udet accueille jusqu'au 20
octobre une exposition du musée
Abbé-Pierre sur les caricatures de ce
dernier dans la presse ces quatre
séquences s'articulent autour euh ben
des des étapes fortes de l'abé pierre
notamment euh les années 50 avec l'appel
de l'hiver 54 en 1954 l'Abbé Pierre
publie une lettre ouverte dans le Figaro
où il raconte comment un bébé est mort
de froid dans la nuit dans dans un
contexte où le gouvernement refusait
d'accorder de l'argent pour loger les
sans abris puis les caricatures dans la
presse étrangère ensuite les caricatures
de l'abbé Pierre dans les années 80 90
et donc ensuite les années 2012 et
l'année abbé piierre se poursuit à
coignère mardi 10 octobre la ville
organise un cinédbat à l'espace Alphonse
d'udé autour du film I feel good le
directeur du musée Abé piierre de
l'association Solidarité nouvelle pour
le logement des Yvelines et le président
d'emahus strapp répondront aux questions
des spectateurs